there's an unspoken question in every
person's mind that has to First be
answered which is why should I listen to
you imagine you're talking to a guy you
don't know anything he's just like
talking about business and you're like
oh that's cool and then like two seconds
later it's like dude that guy's a
billionaire
all of a sudden you're like
right
the frame matters so here's how it looks
in the real world all right
hey here's what I did
versus here's what you should do
feel the difference as soon as you point
out people hate you
because it sounds like you're preaching
it sounds like you have an ego and I
just don't think people like that and so
I think it's really speaking on your
truths rather than claiming to know the
truth
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is Heather Torres the host of this
show where we're helping you build your
influence on YouTube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit online business welcome back if
this is your returning time to think
media that song welcome back just came
in my head welcome back welcome back
okay anyways uh if you're brand new with
us we want to say welcome to this show
hopefully someone shared this with you
or you found us somewhere on YouTube or
on the Apple podcast channels and we
want to say welcome every single Tuesday
we deliver a brand new episode to you so
make sure you're locked in subscribed
wherever you consume this content so you
can get the latest episodes that come
out just like this one now we're heading
into part two of our series with Alex
hermosi he was one of our special guests
at our annual conference grow with video
live and we're diving into the second
part of his content and let me tell you
the first part if you didn't listen was
amazing make sure you go back and listen
to the the previous episode so you can
get all the contacts as to why he
started doing YouTube how he made the
mindset shift and how he's been able to
grow his influence to over a million
followers in less than six months it was
a gnomus episode so mark that down for
your next one now today we're going to
be going into more of what he learned
from this experiment of going all in as
a content creator and not just an
entrepreneur he's going to be breaking
down some of the mindset shifts that he
had to go through and a lot of mistakes
that content creators make when they're
getting started I also love that he's
talking about how you don't have to be
an expert to get started but giving you
the tools to actually press record so
we're going to dive into today's episode
with Alex hermosi now if you don't know
who this entrepreneur is you are in for
a treat I've been so impacted by the
work that Alex and his wife Leila
hermosi are doing on the platform of
YouTube but just in general with helping
entrepreneurs learn how to actually get
their message out there and how to build
businesses the right way now Alex
tremozzi is a first generation Iranian
American entrepreneur investor
philanthropist and the founder of
acquisition.com a portfolio company that
does about 100 million dollars a year
he's most known in the online space for
his expertise in customer acquisition
and monetization getting customers and
making money from it through his
experience in scaling companies quickly
Alex is one of the fastest growing
entrepreneurs on social media right now
with his YouTube channel of over 26
million views where he's helping
entrepreneurs learn how to get more
customers he's also the best-selling
authors of one of my favorite books 100
million dollar offer and if you don't
have it definitely pick that one up but
let's jump into part two of our series
with Alex hermosi
foreign
so that concludes section two
how much and how
fantastic
observations
I was going to call it musings
but then I thought no one would know
what that meant so
um
I just gave you the like traditional lip
service on a Content generation model
it's kind of boring and I don't think
it's that interesting which is why I
tried to get through it quickly because
a lot of people ascribe that as the
reason that we grew a lot and I don't
think that's why but I'm presenting it
because I would end up getting a zillion
questions about it and so that's why
it's there I think the real reason that
we were able to grow so I'm going to put
like my real hat on for a minute
um is that and again this is my two
cents
there you go
is that there's an unspoken question in
every person's mind that has to First be
answered which is why should I listen to
you
and I think it's one of the most
profound questions and I think it
influences how people share how people
take your content everything it's the
frame that the content is consumed in so
I'll give you a real world example
imagine you're talking to a guy you
don't know anything he's just like
talking about business and you're like
oh that's cool and then like two seconds
later it's like dude that guy's a
billionaire
all of a sudden you're like
right
the frame matters a lot
Elon Musk makes a tweet that's like I'm
on the toilet and it gets like 500
million shares right this guy's
hilarious right
it's because it's Elon right and he has
a brand that he's established and
there's context there and so I think
that we should have this question
answered for ourselves and our prospects
before creating content all right and so
imagine for a moment that I had done
this whole presentation up to this point
and I had a 1 000 person total audience
between all of those platforms same
presentation
how different would that feel
right just imagine do it on stage you
don't know me and I have a thousand
people on Instagram and that's it
same presentation
you would receive it differently right
right I would because I would think it
was stupid pointless preachy better than
now full of and if you're so good why
don't you do it
that's what I would think right
and so we have to answer the question
why should I listen to you
and I think a lot of you are making
content from a weak frame and that's
just what I see that's just me
witnessing it like you know it's like
the 18 year old relationship coaches you
know what I mean
they're they're real you know like
they're out there some of you are here
right you know or it's like the business
coaches that are doing five thousand
dollars a month
I don't you know I mean I don't have a
lot like you know
so besides all the stuff that we shared
earlier the real reason that I think our
audience is growing is that we're
talking about stuff that we have
evidence to support like that's the real
right so all I said earlier
sure you can do that that worked for me
you might not like Twitter I like
Twitter because it's easy for me it's
not easy for you don't do it right which
is why this worked for me this time
right that's the context but I think
this stuff is the more kind of Eternal
stuff and that's why I was kind of like
excited to get to part three uh yes
uh and so I think it's about having the
evidence for your others and most
importantly for yourself right we built
these other companies first before ever
talking about how to build companies
right and so if you're like great Alex
nice for you so how do I make content
from just starting out
excellent question
so there's two frame shifts that I think
have to occur
do then talk how I versus how to and
give versus get all right so let's start
with the first one
so who here hates this right
um how to live an amazingly happy life
and get everything that you want
from somebody who is doing this
part-time and is still cutting hair
right there's nothing wrong with cutting
hair
but it probably wouldn't make you an
authority on this matter
does that make sense
some of you are doing this
and wondering why it's not working like
I mean my stuff's so much better it
honestly doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
because if I had a thousand people on
state like my followers and I made the
same presentation you wouldn't give
it like I'm trying like real right
and so there's a better way I think all
right so this is Alex's crazy content
creation model trademark pending all
right
step one
dude
step two
talk about what you just did
I know
and then do bigger
this is a complex model I know we're
getting to it so here's how it looks in
the real world all right
hey here's what I did
versus here's what you should do
feel the difference
this is what I did if it works for you
awesome if it doesn't work for you knows
what here's 20 of my clients this is the
stuff that I'm doing with them right now
Rosie was struggling with some skin
condition we started giving her magic
pills and look at her skin now it's
amazing right but like this is what it
might not work for you but this will
work for her this will work for him this
will work for my clients right not what
you should do as soon as you point out
people hate you
because it sounds like you're preaching
it sounds like you have an ego and I
just don't think people like that
and so I think it's also switching from
how I
sort of other way switching from how to
how I so how to build a massive social
media following to how I built the
following that I have
feel a difference
it's really small but really big in
terms of how people interpret your
message because it's like
thank you I appreciate it
I think that what happens is when you
say it that way you're like you're
you're pulling back and saying like hey
like I hope this serves you in some way
like this is like me opening the kimono
this is stuff that's working right now
for me whereas the other way you're at
the pulpit commanding giving demand you
know demands and and commanding people
and I just don't think people like that
I mean how many people their entire
Instagram famous people shaking their
finger at you right it sucks I hate it
right and so I think it's really
speaking on your truths rather than
claiming to know the truth
and I think to hear and there's a
there's a point I probably make later
but I'll bring it up now
is that
everyone is unquestionably
an expert on your own life
no one can question that if I say I had
oatmeal for breakfast this morning I am
untouchable
you know it was kind of lame but but
from the from a factual tape like no one
can challenge me on that like this is
what I eat every day no one's gonna be
like [ __ ] you Alex
harming the planet
right they're not going to say that
because like that's real that's true no
one can touch that right but as soon as
I say you should have oatmeal for
breakfast
right
it's this big of a difference but it
makes all the impact in the world in
terms of how people receive the message
so question
who here makes the content because they
want to become famous and feel good
about themselves
oh
who is making stuff because they want it
to be received and help the audience
right and so the thing is is you have to
feed them and not you
and I think if you can make that shift I
think in my opinion it will be more
effective and so if you look at the
biggest influencers in the business
space because this is a space that I'm
kind of in
you look at these guys I mean shoot half
these guys are talking here so congrats
the the event it's awesome very honored
to be on stage with them
um so that's the acccm at work the Alex
crazy content creation method at work by
the way
um
dude
talk about that you did
which one of these guys made money from
their social media following
made the money they have from the social
media following right
and so how many of these people needed
the followers
none
right people like I want to be the next
this it's like if you want to be the
next that then you got to walk that walk
right
and so you probably won't be respected
as an authority on business until you've
achieved Mega success
the same reason you look at your
competitors like that guy sucks it's
like they're looking at you
right
and it's because why should I listen to
you
and so here's the good news because
you're like well Alex what do I talk
about here's the good news
you can become a niche specific
Authority so rather than going like
here's how to live an amazing life right
that's like you've got to be Jesus Jesus
can do that Jesus can you can't do that
Jesus can do that right
so you got to go from here to like
I'm really good at helping people build
ATM businesses
I'm really good at how people flip
houses in Phoenix right because in that
little ocean that little Pond you can be
king
because you got to compete against 20
guys and you're going to do you got to
walk the talk right you got to do what
you're doing you talk about what you're
doing that's it but you can win in that
little Pond and I'll show you how to
scale from there in a second but you can
do that all right and so this is me when
I started
so I had a couple powerlifting records
and I liked working out right and so
thank you and so the stuff that I did
then was about what I was doing then and
so you can't read it but it says how to
get rid of stubborn fat on your arms and
stomach that's the content I was making
then and who is it relevant for
just the members at my gym
but that was my way of adding value and
already had a rapport with them so
they're like if I'm going to learn about
this identical topic from 100 different
people I'd just rather learn about it
from you because I like you
and I had values based Rapport not
expertise like I had General expertise
because I looked the way I looked but
beyond that I'd have a PhD it's not like
I did a ton of research I read the same
articles and just tried to make it
entertaining that was it and I didn't
become Mega famous for that but this
made me money this made me enough money
to you know grow the company that I had
at the time
and so from there I leveraged that to
grow my first gym and then the gyms
after that right
and then from there once the gyms grew I
started making content about how to grow
gyms why except I knew how to grow gyms
I wasn't like how to scale your SAS
company you know I mean like how to
reach a billion dollar valuation like I
I was like I don't know but this is what
worked for my gyms
and people were like dude this stuff
works I'm like I know because I'm doing
I did this how I do it like I know it
works it's how I do it of course I'm
doing it
here's what's crazy so many people are
talking about and teaching stuff that a
they have never done and B they are
repurposing someone else's content and
making a version of it
some of them are you
[Applause]
and that's the thing is is like when you
start talking in the theoretical and
trying to teach something
it's how to
rather than how I
right so if you do the thing then you
just talk about what you just did now
later on I think it's the the capture uh
capture don't create documents don't
create content but I understand that
that takes resources like it takes money
to get people around you to you know
document your life and all that kind of
stuff like that that's expensive but I
think just even doing Recaps of like
this is the stuff that's working right
now for us in this context
people are like thanks you didn't have
to do that thanks for sharing that stuff
that's working for you
rather than how to
and no if you do it that way you will
not gain a mega following
at first
but you will accomplish
which will set you on the path for you
to be broader later
so the gym Secrets podcast became the
game
that I published from the gym launch
Secrets book which is how to build a
profitable gym to 100 million offers
book
and the difference in scale was pretty
tremendous that's my job Secrets book
but I still think it's a phenomenal book
by the way
um to that book and that book's done
that in less than a year and that other
book's been out like four years
and so it's not
bad it's just sequence
people try and go out of sequence they
try and say like why am I not Tom Billy
you why can't I'm doing everything Tom
Billy's doing except for building Quest
oops
like that's why what he says is relevant
you know what I mean because the thing
is is like
we want everybody here most people seek
truth would you say if you were like
raise your hand if you seek truth okay
so the easiest shortcut for the brain to
seek truth is to look at someone who's
the most extreme version and then think
okay I don't have to apply a lot of
decision making filtering here because
now I can just absorb this because I can
just take this as fact because if Warren
Buffett says this is how I should invest
I feel okay about that Source even if
he's like save your money spend less
than you earn invest dollar cost average
into the s p and don't buy gold right
like he says that stuff and you're like
okay now the stay-at-home teacher who's
been saving all of her money could say
the exact same thing but she just forgot
to build Berkshire Hathaway
and so the thing is is that and I'm I'm
actually very against the whole
confidence Mantra of like people being
like you got to believe in yourself you
gotta
you have to do things so that you have
evidence that you can support why you
are good
[Applause]
you guys are great
and this is like my favorite line from
The Matrix it's I think in the second or
third I can't remember which one it is
but Morpheus is up there and he's like I
feel truthfully unafraid not because of
the path that lies before me because of
the path lies behind me
and I think
I think it gives a lot of spiritual
strength
that because I I got asked on an
interview they're like how are you so
certain I was like
you talk about these things like with so
much certainty I was like well that's
just how I've done it like and it's that
depth of experience and knowledge that
like no one can question that we built
those things that's truth those are the
real numbers
and so as long as you're not fudging
your numbers right and you just say like
this is what it is then of course you're
certain
right because I think confidence is
self-delusion it's trying to make up for
what you don't have evidence for and I
think it's a much easier practice to
stop pretending and start doing the
stuff that you should be certain about
and then you don't have to have bravado
you can get up like you can walk on
stage and people are like
that guy built the big the biggest king
and water Empire out there nobody clones
in the front
and and he built that
he doesn't have to have confidence for
people to listen to him they will want
to listen to everything that he says if
that is what they want to do because
they'll just go to the person that's
done the thing that they want to do so
that they don't have to apply a lot of
effort in thinking and they can just say
I'll do everything this person says
right
most people cannot separate information
from source
so what we do is we just seek out good
sources I think wisdom is built through
being able to take from separating
information from source
a fool can give you a very wise piece of
wisdom or information or a lesson but
it's much harder to do that and so the
shorthand for most of us is just go to
somebody who's an absolute Authority in
this thing that has unquestionably a
reason that I should listen to them and
then just listen to them the downfall of
that is that you start taking stock
advice from your hairdresser I'm not
bashing hairdressers right now this is
top of mind right and so you're like I
trust you
what else you got and then they start
talking about things that are not their
expertise and then that's when you get
in trouble and so the same degree if you
probably have an audience that's asking
you questions right anybody have an
audience to ask some questions raise
your hand okay
if someone asks you a question that is
not something that you have authority on
I think you gain more Authority by
saying I don't have authority to speak
on that
and then you gain more respect because
because this is what happens
damaging admissions are the single
greatest thing that built Trust
if I say
I suck at marriage advice I suck at you
know giving happiness advice I suck at
whatever
but I'm really good at making high
returns in the stock market
how much more believable is that than
I make really good returns in the stock
market and I'm really good at marriage
and I'm real and and and when you admit
your deficits
whatever comes after the admission of
guilt or the admission of of deficiency
is believed more so if I say hey I
really suck at a lot of things but
you're going to believe what I suppose I
say right here
that's a sentence structure for
persuasion
and you can use that in all of the
content that you have forever
it's also great for negotiating and so
anyways I say all this to say
it's the path that lies behind you not
the path that lies in front of you that
will give you the certainty that you
want to gain the influence you desire
and so my Evolution for me was Fitness
First and I just talked about this is
what's worked for me people are like
Alex how do you eat Twizzlers and
cookies all day and have a six-pack and
I'm like a genetics B
I live at a gym
and see I eat this way right and people
are like oh so I can have cookies too
and have a six-pack and I was like yes
and that was relevant for me some people
are like super vegan Superstars awesome
and they're going to talk what was
relevant for them and the people who
follow it will be like that I I Vibe
with that cool right and so I'm not
going to be the best nutrition expert in
the world but in terms of like my little
little Fife Dome I can rule that right
and then I moved up because I started
doing well there and people started
asking me hey how are you growing your
gym I was like well this is how I grow
my gym
we were like what about business in
general like I don't know I'm never in
an e-commerce business I don't know
about manufacturing I don't know about
software I don't have any of that stuff
but not a grow gym
so it only talks about that
and the amount of people that that was
relevant for
this many but for that audience
everything
right
I mean and just for context here there
are riches and niches
like that company
made a lot of money
um just saying like it made a lot of
money and it didn't make me famous at
all and so again the question is do you
want to be rich do you want to be famous
are you trying to serve you you're
trying to serve the audience right
and then the last one is like now we've
been able to leverage that initial
success to build an e-commerce brand to
build a software brand to sell those and
then now we have a portfolio and so now
because we have businesses that span a
lot of different areas I can say these
are the Frameworks that we used to build
all of them
I hope this serves you
and then people can take that and has
anybody used any of the Frameworks that
we've for Mosey Nation anybody who's
been there have anybody used those
Frameworks to make more money
one person oh probably not
so a big part of that is that
you just get better over time
and so I said this quote and it went it
got shared a lot it's like you're not
making as much money as you want because
you're not as good as you think you are
I'm just being real like I don't know I
could have done like the here's my 17
000 content model you know what I mean
but like the real is that you're
probably not that good yet
comma and that's okay
like the only person beating you up is
you
right
and so
the only way to get better is volume
and the only way to get even better than
volume is volume times time
because volume you can write this down I
don't have this in the presentation but
this is like the equation of life
volume or at least business volume
times
time
equals skill
you got to do it a lot of times for a
long period of time and you will get
better
that is a promise you will if you suck
today you will suck less tomorrow and
eventually one day you will look up and
suck so little that you will actually be
good
and then people will ask you how did you
become an overnight success
and then instead of saying here's how
you cold call you say here's how I did
it
I hope this serves you
right and you can build that trust that
way
great Alex so how do I make money if I'm
just starting out fantastic all right
Colton geez always about the money okay
I'm kidding oh that's awesome
um so here's a couple observations here
give away the secrets sell the
implementation
all right
if you want to build an Enterprise that
is valuable this is how you do it you
can sell info there's nothing wrong with
that but if you want to build a brand
give away the secret sell the
implementation all right
because people are like you can give the
whole Farm away people still won't do it
one percent of people will do it
my business model relies on the one
percent who do it I mean so like I Bank
on that but only one percent are gonna
do it so most people need help
most people need encouragement most
people need accountability most people
need somebody who's going to act as
their virtual Google
because they don't want to type it in
it's true right and so one of the side
notes that I have here is that if you're
not afraid of what you're giving away
that you're giving away too much you're
not giving away enough
and so every time I've written a book or
I've made like a presentation that ends
up going
live I always think to myself like
oh God I'm sharing everything
what will they do they won't need me
anymore because I give them this
information they can they don't they'll
just keep living their lives and I will
become obscure and nothing you know and
I will die right that is what it feels
like I mean you catastrophize but but
that's real right it's the
it's the opposite though right and
there's so many things I feel like that
I that I've at least realized for me is
a lot of things are the opposite of what
you expect it's like you only gain your
life by giving it
right like you only get trust from
others by trusting first
you only get value back by giving Value
First
and so if you're afraid of giving away
all the secrets that you have I promise
you if you make content that does not
contain the secrets 99 of people who are
the people who are never going to pay
you anyways 99 of people will just think
you suck
because you give nothing
so you just make fluff because you're so
afraid of giving good stuff away
the thing that most people consume is
they make one they consume one video and
they make a judgment and say I will
never consume a video from this person
again what a waste of time
and so like my big fear
with every piece of content is I would
rather make fewer pieces of content
because I'm so afraid of somebody taking
20 minutes to consume something after
watching a bunch of my stuff watching
that one and not actively deciding to
stop watching but just just don't get
enough for the time that they're like
I'll just watch something else they
don't say like off they just
pivot a little bit and slowly you fade
away and so I would rather have quality
over quantity
but quality quantity beats just just
quality right but I would personally
this is me I would personally prefer to
have better stuff and give away as many
Secrets as I possibly can to get people
to start taking steps towards you
because what also happens is if someone
goes and uses stuff from the YouTube
channel and grows from a million dollars
a year to three million dollars a year
or five million dollars a year they
don't have questions on whether or not
we can provide value because we already
have
right and then it makes the sales
process dramatically easier because you
say what brought you here today and
they're like well you made me two
million dollars a year I love you and
you're like awesome want to get to 10.
and they're like sure
like
how do I know it's going to work because
it already has
right and you can take that it's a
totally different totally different
frame for the sale
okay
and so make your free materials better
than everyone else's paid materials I
heard this from Tony Robbins and I think
it's really true
but I think the real real is that
most of your stuff is not better than
their paid stuff
and so that's why it doesn't work
and so talk about you really know which
is your specialty which is your
individual thing that you have
experienced that no one can challenge
your truth
all right
and so finally you want to play games
where if you wait you win
because Goodwill compounds faster than
money because the longer you can delay
the ask the bigger the ask can be the
longer the runway the bigger the plane
that can take off of it
and so I promise you and this is again
gigantic Himalayan grain of salt
with the limited experience that I have
uh doing organic because I've only done
direct to jugular paid ads
um cold calling you know affiliate stuff
straight pitching
I've only done that but I can say that
this brand is very special to me because
I enjoy we're building and I'm in no
rush to do it and you have time and so
the longer you can wait and keep walking
with people the longer the compounding
works in your favor like it's no
coincidence that the biggest people in
the business space don't need anything
from their audiences
right because I think that that
compounding process gets interrupted
when you do a hard pitch that's my
opinion I could be wrong that's my
opinion and so
the idea is how can we
hack when we sell without selling
right and I think in that way the
compounding will happen faster than the
revenue would have otherwise increased
if you started trying to make the money
fast and so the longer you can delay
that the better it's going to be and
then you can understand why all these
guys play the infinite game of never
even wanting to do that right hook
because it's like but next year I'm
going to have five times the audience
and then a year later they're like but
next year I'm going to have five times
the audience right because as soon as
you you shoot your shot you dramatically
decrease the Goodwill and so I think
that I've at least adapted and this is
maybe just a different way of saying it
I know Gary's got uh jab jab jab right
hook
just a personal observation that I've
had is that you can go give give
give
you don't even have to ask people just
start handing things to you because if
you deposit enough Goodwill in there
it just starts coming back and I know
that sounds crazy but like the amount of
people that DM you're like Hey man can I
give you 10 grand for 10 minutes I'm
like no
I don't do that like about 20 grand like
no I don't do that right the amount of
times people inbound and they're like
hey can I have you on my podcast can I
have you on my stage can I all these
things are happening because you're not
asking for anything and it makes people
feel uncomfortable
like it makes people feel really
uncomfortable they're like how can I buy
something from you and you're like you
can't they're like ah
and I'm like use this get to three
million then we can partner right but
but that's it you know I mean there's
nothing else and so I think that if we
can make that pivot and have that
patience uh but like if we're thinking
really big picture the reason most
people aren't successful is they just
can't control themselves like that's it
it's impulse control
and so there's three things they did
this research study that said that Ultra
success Ultra successful people have
three common traits number one is they
have a superiority conflict they think
they're better than everybody they think
they they can do bigger things
second is that they are they have
crippling insecurity of not being enough
I like that one hits me and then the
third one is impulse control
so they know where they want to go
they have a waif they have a way drive
to not be a failure and they stay
focused on it because of impulse control
and so the idea here is if we can do
that
we will be more successful and the
reason that most people don't make money
is because they can't wait 12 months
like I had this I have this 18 year old
who was my neighbor and I said I'm going
to have you sign a contract that says I
want to be a millionaire I was like
you gotta wait five years
you can't make any money between now and
then would you do it he's like yeah I
would do it
every single person can do that I
guarantee you if you delayed after five
years and you should provide a value to
people for five years you'd have bigger
audience than you know what to do with
and you'd be a millionaire in five years
probably happening a lot faster than
that but if you committed to doing it
for five years you would but guess what
No One's Gonna Do It
and that's why most people are
successful and so if we come to these
events and you have the models and all
the stuff
right but people still eat cookies when
they're trying to lose weight
and so
it's a concept of local versus global
which is there's a local benefit to
eating cookies you feel better whatever
the global benefit goes down though
because you don't get the six-pack you
want if that's the goal and you're
counting macroses you get the idea right
and so most people cannot sacrifice
local benefit for Global
the sales guys don't want to put the
notes in the CRM
even though the benefits the entire
organization
because it's a local cost right
and so as a side note for operations for
a business operations are supposed to
bring Global benefit in excess of the
local cost
um
and so when we're trying to achieve the
things that you're trying to do right
the local benefit is just make the ask
fast
the global benefit is the longer you can
wait the bigger it can be
and so for me I'm like why not wait as
long as humanly possible so
I'll wrap this up
speak from strength share your
experiences to add to the body of
knowledge the problem with a lot of the
Social Media stuff and books that are
out there now is that the the barrier to
entry in terms of what it takes to
publish content is so low it's almost
not visible right so low
and so everybody can produce content
back in the day the only way you produce
content was like after 30 years of being
a researcher you're like this is my
entire life's work in one book so I can
add to the body of knowledge
people were like wow thank you for that
and that's how that's how content was
made right and if you wanted to do a
direct uh you know a marketing piece you
had to edit it and put it on a piece of
paper and look at it every single way
and know that you're gonna pay 50 cents
for every single person who's gonna
receive it and you better be damn sure
it's beautiful right
but people don't want like it's so easy
now to publish that most stuff is [ __ ]
right most stuff sucks and is a total
waste of time so just try and talk about
the stuff that's not a waste of time
that you actually know so you can add to
the body of knowledge if you say hey
this is what I did consider yourself a
mini researcher
like these are the experiments I ran in
my business these are the experiments I
ran in my weight loss clinic these are
the experiments I ran in my Plumbing
business
just talk about the experience because
no one can question that
second is that teaching on principles is
difficult until you've achieved a
material amount in the field because
there are others who will teach you with
more depth of experience
it's very difficult to teach business
unless you're very successful business
because there's just another person who
someone will listen to more right but no
one can question what you have done and
if you have done nothing then do
something first and then talk about it
because not everyone is an expert on
everything but you are unquestionably an
expert on your own life so you can share
it all right and then wait 10 years
well I hope you got value out of the
part two and the entire series with the
best entrepreneur right now for me Alex
hermosi I'm so inspired by seeing how uh
how he said you know it wasn't really
about the camera equipment it was about
the quality of the content he was doing
that was such an impact in the aha
moment that I hope that you got from it
and if you like content like this then
you definitely want to go to
21videotips.com where you're going to
get 21 amazing tips from entrepreneurs
like Patrick that David Vanessa Lau Pat
Flynn and so many more also Alex or
Moses in there as well where you're
going to be learning some of their
little-known business secrets and inside
of this resource we're giving you a
downloadable guide that goes along with
it to help you get impact right away so
go to
21videotips.com right now to get that
free resource and this incredible video
that has 21 amazing tips from special
guests just like this now if you've not
yet rated and reviewed this show I'm
going to encourage you to do that also
this is where you can go to Apple
podcast and leave a rating and review
five stars please is what I'm asking for
no you can rate whatever you want but
this is where we get to share one of our
uh think fam members and we are doing an
international series and so today comes
from inverted popes from the UK I
believe the truth at last always great
insightful podcast and love listening to
them today this podcast was gold for the
first time I heard exactly what needs to
be said and rarely is well thank you
inverted popes for leaving that review
thank you for being one of our
International listeners and sharing this
podcast with other people just like you
now if you know someone in your life who
needs the information that you just got
from this series I'm going to encourage
you to share it with them send them a
text tweet it out whatever you need to
do to get this into the hands of people
that you know need it definitely do that
now well thank you so much for being a
part of what we're doing here at think
media so grateful for you for uh leaving
those reviews for watching and for
subscribing over on YouTube and on the
podcast and we will catch you in the
next episode bye
[Music]